hey
everybody it's us it's wednesday yeah
right yeah we got a lot of people in
there
all the all the uh all the regulars oh
[ __ ] i got the damn
every time that [ __ ] down yeah why do
you do that
god damn it i don't know that's how i do
my sleep damn it
damn because i thought of something
and it was something from a long time
ago the other man reacted to him he did
seriously it's like
it's like he has tourette's address yeah
it's like tarantula because it's just
like he'll just be sitting i think he's
mad at me about something something bad
happened he'll just be like over there
at random and all of a sudden he'll be
like damn god damn
well sometimes it's it's being sore too
you know what i mean like if i'd worked
out or something i'll be real [ __ ]
sore and i'll just roll over and go god
damn
[Laughter]
you know this is why i don't get any
sleep it's not that bad
it's not that bad i mean they got
[ __ ] badgers that do that they just
walk around [ __ ] cussing
nothing's even happening yeah but i'm
like you know you remind me of that i
know exactly what you're going through
dude
you know [ __ ] walking around mad you
know
[Laughter]
yeah for real yeah well look i got my
other movie in
he's very excited this is jesse
eisenberg double feature yeah eisenberg
double feature
[Laughter]
bavarium this was a good focus
that was one of my favorite movies that
we thought some of my army buddies saw
it because i
recommended it and they came back and
cussed me out [ __ ] and i just watched
you know what i mean they're not real
imaginative
and i said well think of it like
predator predator one
except it's happening in another
dimension and it's making you raise its
baby
and they were like oh yeah okay i guess
that's what that meant
you know it's kind of silly though and
as man go ahead go ahead on
dumb people shouldn't watch movies yeah
it's a good movie it is like i said it's
one of it's actually one of my favorite
movies
there was just something really really
like creepy and like twitch
about it it's like a long twilight zone
ep episode and it's just weirder and
weirder [ __ ] was happening
and i didn't know what was going to
happen now that i know what's going to
happen i want to see it again
see what i missed yeah that's definitely
one of those ones where like
now that you know like the secret or you
know where the end's going to be like
you want to go back and like watch it
again
like yeah we'll have to watch it this
weekend saw this one for like the third
time
last night it's another eisenberg movie
um
we talked about it yesterday artists out
the fence and i just saw more into it
it is the movie that i thought it was it
is a damn masterpiece
you know it's a masterpiece what what
this one is about
it's about masculinity all right
through the eyes of a [ __ ] soy boy
all right
the guy who wrote the screenplay is soya
[ __ ]
he's on the [ __ ] dvd talking about it
all right he said that men
scared him you know what i mean they
they were toxic masculinity and [ __ ] and
it was scared
so he he is the [ __ ] main character
in this story that's him but then as it
as now that i've seen it third time
three times
sensei is also the same character all
three of them are the same person in
different
in different uh stages of development
because
it's about guys trying to become what
they fear
so they've kind of internalized [ __ ]
um evil in a way yeah but it is a dark
comedy
it's pretty cool i like sensei in it
even though he's a [ __ ] psycho
you know he's a [ __ ] psycho and
what's funny is that i
i don't know if the writer
really understood the story that he told
because he doesn't have any personal
experience in any of this
he saw his [ __ ] you know still is all
right
the at the end of the movie it comes
right around and embraces [ __ ]
karate it embraces karate at the end
the the idea behind it it was and then
and it also
embraced masculinity at the end of it i
don't know if he realized that but it
did
because sensei's version of masculinity
was
fake masculinity well yeah toxic
masculinity is always
fake i mean i always i thought that was
pretty clear and from a writer's
standpoint i would think that that would
happen okay i
i i guess he understood it yeah all
right um because the the movie
was pretty smart at spreader types yeah
the movie was not the movie was not
anti-karate and it's not anti-man
uh it's it's it's very good and it has a
lot of
important philosophical lessons in the
[ __ ] movie
about the nature of good and evil and
where it comes from
do you like it yeah okay you know i like
that all right you talk about it
i'm just sitting there like i don't want
this [ __ ] talking about the damn
movie what do you want to talk about
well no i just said well because you
talked about it yesterday
because you just got it well no because
may goes on mango's on there right now
and he tried to
he tried to watch it last night all
right we were talking about it
oh okay well i don't know all right yeah
well i was doing a show you see there's
things that you didn't know
you didn't well you didn't tell me i
didn't shouldn't have to tell you you
supposed to be my partner
me and you like i'm supposed to be yeah
like wingman you know you're supposed to
know
i'm supposed to know supposed to know
that i know what i'm doing
let's see what mango's saying now no
what is why i didn't know that was
because
last night i did a live show uh
conspira normal what they've been doing
adam sane and company yeah um
in the kind of uh you know going up to
the strange realities conference which
starts on september 25th
um they're kind of having like all the
speakers that are gonna be at the
conference
they're gonna they're having them on
like you know two or three at a time
and they're doing like a live hour just
as kind of like a teaser for people like
to get people to buy tickets to the
conference and stuff so
i was on there last night with uh
stephanie quick
and kiki dombrowski and uh it was just
kind of like it was just a fun like kind
of loose hour we kind of like talked a
little bit about what we were going to
talk about at the conference and we just
kind of like shot the [ __ ] i talked
about the podcast song i talked about
the case i was going to talk about
all that kind of stuff so it was kind of
fun also
i just got a message the other day that
uh earlier today rather
that um tim bernal from
banal america or in all of america or
whatever it's called it's like affiliate
coast to coast i am
um i he wants me to be on the show
friday night for coast to coast or or
his own his show yeah
i'm not sure if it's live or if it's
recorded he just wanted me to be on he
said
friday night from 9 to 11. okay cool so
i just found out about that what topic
you know i don't know
i guess i'll figure it out everybody
starts asking me questions
i haven't heard coast to coast in a long
time since art died i wonder
i wonder what coast coast is up to now
well actually art left
coast to coast then he went and did his
own thing you had old what's his name on
there
what's his name oh what's his name with
jackhole what jackal there's that's
that's a very broadcaster yeah jackal
got guy who took art belle's place
who was oh george george nori and george
murray was a dick
i saw him really mistreat some [ __ ]
guests before
yeah he really was very condescending
yeah
i don't know what the hell happened he
just yeah if a guest
you know said something or sneezed too
many times oh i can't have this on
on air you know i mean he [ __ ] did he
totally did that yeah because it got
coughed too
yeah because that guy had like a cold or
something like that he's getting through
the show he's all right
yeah he was all right i just can't have
this why don't i just call you back
whenever
we'll reschedule or something like that
he got like really like butter and the
guy's like what
and he's like yeah yeah yeah i knew he
was [ __ ] but i heard about it and
then like uh
it's not like the guy was going like
into the microphone
and then and then and then then we had
to put up [ __ ] george nori for a
couple of hours
just dumb ass yep and about whatnot
yeah but yeah so it's like i don't know
oh louie said it was strange seeing
jenny without time oh you watched that
oh okay
yeah i was actually talking to him
before yeah
for a few minutes like a nerd i went in
there before because they're using um
they're setting up this it's called
stream yard
and they um are gonna be using that for
the conference so they
that was another reason like why they
wanted to do all of this like uh
you know previous like teaser shows so
they could kind of like
you know figure out how it worked and
like you know perfect everything
and um so i had never used it before
either so me being like paranoid and
knowing
like with technical things that anything
that can go wrong will go wrong
so it's like as soon as they sent me the
link i like went in there
like not really knowing what was gonna
happen
so i was sitting there in them with for
with them for like
half an hour while they were like
working out all the bugs with the green
screen and
all that other kind of stuff and i'm
just kind of sitting there going hey you
guys
yeah but i was on there before it was a
lot of talking to everybody
but you guys missed you all right jenny
uh you better shut me off like george
nori
[Music]
are you sick no i have no i have
heartburn
okay i was supposed to be the red beans
of rice
yeah that's why it's good but it always
gives me really bad heartburn i thought
he was gonna like get up and like push
me out of here about my rolling chair
you have to roll you have to
pull a nori
[Laughter]
oh wow that's like shut me out of the
frame
i got a [ __ ] i had to do a george
nori [ __ ] voice
i got a [ __ ] practice i can't even
remember what his voice sounds like
because you used to listen to that all
the time
you used to listen to that it was kind
of mushmouth uh
okay yeah yeah yeah i didn't really like
nori
no i didn't either like i said he just
he came across as like a barely
restrained like
douche canoe yeah yeah and it's you know
what i mean it's like it he couldn't
help like it leaking out
it was yeah and art art was art was the
[ __ ] he was he was just a fun guy to
listen to he could just make the dumbest
[ __ ] topic sound really [ __ ] cool
yeah just there's something about art
belle's voice there was somebody who
bought his
archive and was streaming that [ __ ] on
on youtube all his old shows
yeah yeah i haven't seen it streamed a
while but it's probably you can find it
it was like art bill 24 7. it was
somebody owns the archive is it wasn't
getting flagged yeah
yeah it's kind of neat to hear those old
shows
well that's pretty cool i mean you know
there's an audience out there for it
it's like look even a couple people
in the comments said they still listen
to that stuff yeah it's good it's nice
to have something that you can listen to
that's like just in the background like
when i'm working on stuff
like um you know if i'm doing some
graphic design work or something like
that that doesn't
that doesn't need like a lot of like
reading or concentration or something
i like to listen to this i just found
this guy like a few because i really
like mr nightmare and all that kind of
stuff like all the scary stories like
from reddit and stuff
but i found this other guy uh his
channel is called be
busta and he's from he's australian
and he has a great voice and like so he
reads like all these like true ghost
stories and like skin walkers and all
this other kind of stuff
and he'll do like these massive shows
that are like three or four hours long
that are just like three or four hours
of scary stories
and it's like it's really nice to like
put that on in the background yeah
and it's not you know what i mean and it
doesn't have like like any
you know goofy sound effects or anything
like that usually yeah it's just kind of
his cool voice like in the background
telling you all those creepy [ __ ]
the one i could listen to forever is
[ __ ] uh
when art would have that damn that
[ __ ] dude that would just talk about
mars
i forgot the guy's name that is the only
show that i remember was
like the elevator to mars man right was
that the same guy uh-uh
i don't i don't think so who was the
elevator to mars man i don't know
but why don't i ever why do i remember
that one
i really don't have any idea what you're
talking about there's this guy who
his whole specialty was talking about
sindonia i think is what he called it he
had named
the place where the face was and the
said there were pyramids there and that
you know they're trying to line all this
[ __ ] up and he's sitting
there that dude would [ __ ] for
[ __ ] hours and
what do we have over here if we look in
this corner
we plainly see across this what it would
have looked like
millions of years ago and then art's
going all right
yeah yeah i see something oh yeah
because
millions what we're looking at here are
this is an
international airport on mars and you
know
oh it sure is it does look a lot like an
international airport
if you you can lay lax right over this
and you can see that this is almost an
exact
reproduction of lax
who is that dude's name but come on
mandy sindonia
i don't remember that guy's name that
doesn't yes yeah yeah yeah totally legit
somebody in the it's somebody in there
oh the art bill archive got taken down
oh [ __ ] oh man so i guess he didn't own
it
maybe go some maybe somebody else has
put it up like on like
whitney street vimeo or something no no
no no no that was that was the guy that
wrote communion and
yeah yeah yeah he got kidnapped by
aliens he also wrote the hunger
though yeah crazy he is crazy yeah
it's crazy i was thinking of the the guy
maybe you guys might remember his name
he was he was the one that would just go
on and on about what was on
i can see his face but i can't think of
what his name is yeah and he's still
around trying to lie about mars
well it's a lucrative i mean it's a
lucrative thing to go around
if you can go around and i in a way i
kind of admire
the grift because i i mean although some
of these people might not be
knowingly grifting they might just be
like going around doing this because
they actually believe it
but if they're not i do actually admire
a person that can just go around and
just tell
all these bald-faced porkies as they
would say in the uk
um just with a totally straight face and
like not
crack up or be like yeah i'm just
[ __ ] the mar the mars dude had an
excuse
back in those days because there wasn't
any real clear photography
yeah so you could use your imagination
now you got rovers that have [ __ ]
been in there you've been seeing all
that [ __ ] [ __ ] well yeah but you can
still continue the grift because then
you can say that all that [ __ ] was faked
see yeah you could say like the rover
never went there it was just going
around
the thing with those types of theories
is that you no matter what evidence
comes out to the contrary
then they will just think of some way
around it because mars i think
if i remember correctly has it has some
good satellites in orbit around it now
and i think every square inch of it's
been photographed like in hd
yeah maybe the satellites have covered
it pretty well they're going to send
that damn helicopter there i think that
left a couple days ago i'm not sure
but you know like i said that that's not
gonna that's not gonna like deter
anybody that's really into that kind of
stuff because they're so invested
whether they're making a bunch of money
at it or whether
you know they actually do believe it
once you go that far down the path and
you're
that invested in that theory then
nothing that anybody says to you richard
hoagland yep
that's it that's richard hogan that's it
i knew i knew his name but i couldn't
richard hoagland is still out there as
far as i as far as i know still [ __ ]
telling tales about [ __ ] mars and
ancient ruins on mars
and i'm sorry there's no ancient ruins
on mars not on the surface
to be honest you probably are safer
talking about like atlantis and [ __ ]
yeah you know what i mean because it's
like there's like a lot of the ocean and
stuff that hasn't been
i mean yeah that could still be down
there somewhere it could be like super
deep where we can't get to but mars has
been pretty well mapped well there's
already a bunch
there's already some there's a lot of
cool [ __ ] out in just in the solar
system that needs to be looked at i mean
oh there's a good chance that there's
microbial life on mars
it's going to be oh i don't i you know i
don't doubt that it's going to be on
underneath the surface yeah and uh
there's a very good chance that there's
some um life on on in the oceans of
europa
yeah uh i think that's actually very
light you're right that's probably
little salt water build airports what's
that
little microbes don't build airports
[Laughter]
i'm sure there was probably some surface
life on mars at one time but i don't
think it ever got very advanced i mean
you
probably may be talking about coral
maybe it would have been ocean life i
think probably really nothing even on
the surface
yeah it'd probably been like the same
[ __ ] that you saw here like you know the
real primitive ocean yeah
that's kind of what i feel not even fish
yet probably just things like
corals and maybe uh things kind of like
worms maybe
yeah something like that but we have
several people saying we should do a
show on artbell
i'll write down that time how do you do
a show on our well i don't know i'll
just write it
live and i'll put it in the topic box
okay
and then when it comes up in the polls
and if you want us to do it then
vote for it you know what i mean
somebody when i was doing the show last
night uh
adam saying asked me like what what we
were gonna do for the halloween show
and i was like holy [ __ ] dude didn't
forget about it well
i didn't forget about it it's just that
since we started doing the polls
and stuff i guess i can do like like if
i can think of like five topics to put
in the poll that are kind of halloween
themed
but i don't know because i was kind of
like i like doing a special for
halloween but i told him on the show
last night i was kind of like
we used to do you know halloween we'd do
like a big like two or three hour show
and it's like now every [ __ ] week our
show is like four hours long so it's
like
it's now i feel like obligated it's like
dude to do a special one we have it has
to be like [ __ ] six hours or
something
yeah they're asking about mark thank you
very much thank you very much bro when's
my birthday september 26th
yeah yeah somebody was asking you know
have they ever
landed on venus and they did it's back
in the 70s
uh venus you're never really gonna do
much with venus it's very high
atmospheric pressure and uh real hot
got a real intense uh greenhouse effect
yeah aren't all those clouds like it's
like a [ __ ] ammonia yeah
the atmosphere is real toxic you're
talking um
uh hydro like hydro sulfuric acid
is like a one of the major things in the
atmosphere
and chlorine and [ __ ] like that it's
[ __ ] bad real bad
um now they're talking about
terraforming
mars mars is never really going to be a
good planet to live on for very long
it's it's very low mass
that's what's wrong with it it doesn't
have enough of a gravitational pull
to maintain an atmosphere for very long
you know maybe
oh thank you mark thank you very much
tired of waiting happy birthday
thanks thank you very much that's right
we got mark sending us some damn flash
balls
that's my birthday monday yeah
you're gonna be an old bat you're not
that old
you keep you keep sending uh [ __ ] like
that mark and i'll go have her uh
rebuilt
i'll go take that same classic surgeon
that
damn barbara eden had he's gonna have to
be rebuilt
i'll have her [ __ ] rebuild it from
the ground up
but uh she'll come out here you look
like a [ __ ] porn star
can i can i have 6 million manpowers you
can have 16 million dollars we'll put
your bionic legs and eyes
yeah i was trying to talk about
something intellectual and you [ __ ] me
up i don't remember what it was
yeah how does it feel i don't remember
what
i remember what it was
um the problem with mars is that it was
uh it's
it doesn't have enough mass it's too
small so any atmosphere you give it will
leak out eventually
so you might be able to
unlock some water you know and get some
water going try to maybe get some kind
of an atmosphere
but it wouldn't it wouldn't maintain it
for very long
the atmosphere is very thin people don't
realize it's only a little bit thicker
than the moon
um it has 200 mile an hour winds but it
doesn't even blow
because there's no density to it it's
it's so thin
but venus actually it might be a better
place to terraform
but you have to get rid of that
atmosphere yeah if we could blow that
atmosphere
and there was ways where they talked
about you might be able to
bombard it with stuff is this thank you
very much
thank you zach fix that you're not old
jen do a story reading for halloween
yeah i might i might actually do that
again
you might be able to bombard venus with
a bunch of comets or something
and um try to push off that old
atmosphere or maybe put something like
wayland industry
[ __ ] uh uh
nuclear reactors that [ __ ] change the
atmosphere into something else through
some kind of chemical process you might
be able to get some of that toxicity out
maybe [ __ ] up its ozone and stop the
damn greenhouse effect that might help
because really venus
is like earth's twin it's just a little
bit closer
to the sun yeah and the main difference
is just
that the greenhouse effect it didn't
evolve the same way the earth did
um but you might be able to get it to a
it would still take a long time
it's very nearly the same size it's just
like a small a little bit smaller
yeah and i think it's i think it's uh
the actual the surface it's
core and everything are real similar in
makeup you
probably have a lot better chance of
terraforming venus than you would
mars you could live on mars right now
if you brought technology with you but
you'd never be able to step outside like
you would and enjoy the day like you
would you know
on earth just walk outside there i feel
like oh my skin fried off yeah now it's
cold
it's pretty cold um it well now actually
it depends
uh summer around the equator time it can
get in the 70s
uh but the at atmospheric pressure is
very low you know it would kill you
um you know
you pop like a tick you kind of pop
probably um fourth jordan says i heard
an interview with a scientist who said
that with modern materials these days
you could build the six million dollar
man for about two hundred thousand
dollars
what a bargain yeah
that was weird though i remember when
that movie came remember when that
program came out man
i love that [ __ ] soundtrack and
looking back on it that was like
very almost like one of the first
industrial songs
industrial music it kind of was yeah
yeah or you can go back and watch some
of those
yeah or maybe you could say uh the theme
to doctor who might have been industrial
it was a bit yeah i was just thinking of
the
mystery science theater sketch where he
rebuilt the bots and gave them uh
improvements and he gave them bionic
noises i like both
theme songs but the six million dollar
man theme song and you british people
can go check that [ __ ] out yourself
was a lot more masculine it was [ __ ]
more
it was more it would have more of a
testosterone
infused sound to it sounded like
you were gonna blow some [ __ ] up when
you're listening to that
cross between astronauts and [ __ ]
blowing up
two of tom's favorite things hell yeah
fishing was a little kid
he's watching it astronauts oh [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] blowing up oh hell yeah
whoa this is the best thing best thing
ever and then there's showing the
[ __ ] schematics of his legs and his
eyes
he ran so fast that he ran in slow
motion
so we started to do that as kids yeah
just once my brother did
[Laughter]
hell yeah you remember that yeah yeah
like i said i'm pretty sure and it was
like
symbolic for you running [ __ ] fast
everybody else will slow down
too that way you can fight slow motion
and you pretend that it was like [ __ ]
matrix [ __ ] we thought of the matrix
before there was matrix we invented that
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
me jimmy and mike jimmy and mike jimmy
and mike north two brothers you're like
give me my royalties now please
yeah he wants all the matrix money oh
yeah they got that from us man
you're like [ __ ] dodging in slow
motion slow motion punches and [ __ ]
yeah yeah they i guess the the cows and
that's
why i did a beach towel around my neck
get my mom's dish gloves and put my
dad's helmet on
get on my shoulders super badass oh it
turned i was turning into [ __ ] evil
knievel
that's adorable we still need to find
i want to find what happened to that
picture of you as a kid where you look
like [ __ ] damien
i have lots of them well yeah because
you did look like damier yeah but there
was one in particular that i was
thinking of
when i was in my military no no because
you were older in that one this one was
one when you were maybe
five what the hell happened to that
picture i thought it was wrong
oh it looked like baby baby damien from
the old
[ __ ] omen right yeah yeah not like
the one from part two right yeah
the military school damian or part three
or whatever that was the one where i was
part three he was a girl i was in that
little african safari outfit
right the black and white photograph it
was black yeah i think it was black yeah
yeah
yeah you you didn't notice with little
chubby cheeks or whatever yeah my mom
had me in an african safari outfit i
just didn't have the pith helmet on oh i
didn't okay i didn't notice that it was
that it was safari i guess because it
was a black and white yeah so i didn't
realize well like what
i'm gonna [ __ ] dress me up as [ __ ]
[Laughter]
dressed me up like a 1700s patriot and
[ __ ] with a three cornered hat and [ __ ]
had one dressed up like a yeah no i was
dressed up like a [ __ ] like like
like uh just like 1700s yeah like paul
revere or something
yeah tricorner hat and stuff
she got that idea she took me to [ __ ]
um one of these little [ __ ] things
out near her house because
she but where was that gettysburg yeah i
think it was gettysburg no not
gettysburg it was another one of those
birds
it was like an iceberg it was a tourist
trap that yeah when you went there it
was like it was back in time like
williamsburg williamsburg williamsburg i
think it was williamsburg
yeah she took me to williamsburg and she
got that [ __ ] she
had the little knee socks
[Laughter]
she dressed me up like a like a like a
dracula i had a dracula outfit okay
that's that's cool
yeah i have that i went trick or
treating in that one yeah
yeah it was made out of rayon it was
she made it yeah i was like my i um
my mom made a lot of my uh halloween
costumes as well like wait i had a few
years where i just had like those crappy
ones that used to just get at 7 11 or
whatever that was just like the plastic
sheath and like the plaid the little
like plastic cheap mascara
was friends with other women who lived
on our [ __ ] block you know like my
friends
my friends moms and they all [ __ ] in
the competition to
make stuff like you know yeah she um
dressed me up as a uh as a jawa
yeah i was in java too yeah my mom made
she had like an old blanket that was
like exactly the same like a wool
blanket that was exactly the same color
as the jawas
uh cloaks so she took that old blanket
and like made the cloak out of it
and then i had like those little glasses
that had like the little red
pinpoint like things and it was all dark
under there and when i went out
trick-or-treating because i grew up in
florida you guys
and um halloween is never cold
ever yeah so uh i went out
trick-or-treating and i was out for
about half an hour and then i had to
come back and change into a different
costume because i was
gonna die of a heat stroke because it
was like a really really
really really hot costume yeah it's on
my big foot in the six minutes
man i remember all that it's funny
because i cuz speaking of it not being
uh not being cold on halloween ever the
first time when i was a kid when i saw
the movie
uh the lady in white and which i guess
is like set up in new england
and it was halloween and they were
talking about how cold it was and i'm
like
what are you talking about it's not cold
on halloween like i didn't understand
that like it was cold on halloween in
other
parts of the country yeah because it's
never cold here on halloween which is a
shame
um business talk about ninja gym what
are you talking about ninja jam i
didn't really care what catch what you
were talking about but yeah i had all
kinds of uh
stuff that i would get got dressed up as
because i wanted to be this or that you
know
i wanted to be an airplane at first that
was the first thing i wanted i wanted to
be a p40 thomas yeah
not a pilot he wanted to be i wanted to
do the airplane yeah that was the first
thing i remember wanting to be and i
wanted to be the airplane
and i wanted to be a p40 tomahawk
because i had one it had the [ __ ]
shagger
mine had the flying tigers
flying tiger mouth painted on it yeah
yeah it was a model
my dad made the model gave it to me and
you're like i want to be i want to be
that airplane
[Laughter]
and then i had a model of dracula
all right and his hands and his face
would glow oh yeah yeah
yeah i know what you're talking about
yeah i had that was that an aurora model
i think so it wasn't painted
it just would glow you know and uh
in the middle of the night that thing
would be [ __ ] glowing and i'd [ __ ]
crack my eye open and look at it and get
scared
well yeah little dracula yeah they're
trying to get you a little boy
yeah and then for some reason i [ __ ]
decided
i was going to be a vampire i was going
to be a dragon we were trying to own
your fear man yeah
because you would be a bigger vampire
though than him yeah so
you were asserting your vampire
dominance yeah
outfit i had a little metal and
everything
to go along with it like a little dragon
dracula metal
and um i was remember walking around
that thing i'm gonna be a dracula
i'm gonna be a dracula not a he's not
gonna be a vampire
little did i know just what
15 20 years later i'm in a goth club a
[ __ ] fang
did you ever actually wear fangs to a
golf club long time ago i don't think i
never knew i don't think i ever knew
that man when they first hit
when they were custom made yeah yeah
yeah and [ __ ] hardly nobody had them
and then um [ __ ] contacts were [ __ ]
when they when they were brand new
[ __ ] they were expensive they were in
and if you had those you were [ __ ]
pimping
you were [ __ ] pimping yeah i remember
that yeah i can never afford them now
they're cheap
well yeah that [ __ ] it's kind of [ __ ]
well for special events you know
some people can pull them off certain
outfits yeah like we went to the vampire
ball at the castle a couple years ago
and i had
i didn't put any fangs in or nothing but
it's like i had red
contacts and i had the whole hair pieces
and all that kind of [ __ ] took me
forever although the outfit that i
wanted to wear didn't work out
so i had to go with plan b i hate when
that happens
you have to do a run through like
rehearsing
oh my goodness is that all that you have
to say
yeah you think it is yeah i remember
yeah he's talking about the aurora kids
i was thinking about getting um
some model kits of the [ __ ] old star
trek
ships i bought some when i was a kid
there was one
little model kit that had the enterprise
a romulan warbird and a [ __ ] klingon
battle cruiser it was all in the same
kit
they weren't very big yeah they were
like that big
yeah eat each one i wonder if those kits
still exist they were like something
that were made in the 60s
i'm sure you could probably find some
but i don't i mean you'd probably have
to pay a pretty penny for them from
unless somebody's got see the mold may
still be out there
yeah so you can still make them that
company might still exist i
found one because i was looking for one
for you for
your birthday or christmas or something
like that and i found one like i found
like a hobby shop that had them
like a new version of it but they were
out of stock i think they were asked out
yeah yeah
and i couldn't find it yeah i wanted i
also like the stuff from like
wrathicon and you know uh [ __ ] star
trek the motion picture the models from
those
yeah [ __ ] yeah there's all that
there's something about that era
the the old original television series
and and the movies with kirk and spock
there's something about the way those
ships looked and they really looked they
just looked really cool
and i think there may be kits out there
with fiber optic filaments so you can
make all the lights and all the windows
[ __ ] light up
and effects yeah yeah if i was gonna
do it was a little hot ass in there in
the window
yeah look you look in the window and
uhura's
sitting there after after i did the show
last night we were watching
uh cat's paw right yeah the old original
star trek episode
which is actually one of my favorite
ones because i like any of the ones that
are
horror based like that one i like the
jack the ripper one where i [ __ ]
yeah where it looks like scotty kill
somebody or does he really kill somebody
or something i've seen that one a couple
times
uh no he gets accused of he gets accused
of killing somebody
and it's like a jack the ripper planet
yeah because of course they have those
yeah
jack the river plant okay the cat's paw
one was like the witchcraft planet
well it wasn't it wasn't it was an alien
it wasn't it was aliens
that were taking that from like memories
or
conscious or something yeah we were
[ __ ] watching we just we were
watching we've been watching the
original um
star trek off and on for the past couple
weeks
yeah like if there's nothing else going
on we don't have anything yeah they're
very comforting
yeah like i said so even we started
watching them like from the beginning
nothing but nothing but good-looking
women on star trek
i know even though all their outfits
look like they're made of like uh sofa
baltimore yeah sofa poster
well but not but in a cool way not the
uniforms
nichelle nichols man she's looking
awesome in that
yeah she's she is awesome everybody was
awesome on that we were laughing because
i always forget even though i've watched
the whole series through probably three
or four times
i always forget that chekhov doesn't
really get into the show until like a
little bit into the season
second season season two yeah and it
took them a while to decide on
what wig they wanted to give him yeah
get some [ __ ] up hair he'd have
different haircuts every time he said
they were trying to get him to look as
much like davey jones as possible i
guess
but it's like it wasn't really working
out yeah so it's like the one we watched
last night or the night before like i
was just kind of like oh this wig was
not not a good idea it's like some of
me looked good but then there was one
wig
where it was kind of like all swept to
one side but then there was just like
this one piece that was just like
hanging there like that
and my hair does that sometimes too so i
feel so i feel him but like
i was like didn't somebody why didn't
they fix that it's like they could have
like fixed it with hairspray or
something that was like really really
bothering me
but yeah so uh yeah we can go ahead and
shut it off all right
so anyway hopefully you guys have a
good rest of your wednesday we will be
uh back on the live stream as usual
saturday night for the big episode we'll
be drinking
yup talking about a fascinating topic as
usual yeah this next one's going to be
good good you guys are going to win
yeah it'll be super fun it's kind of a
paranormal one yeah sort of
yeah i guess it kind of is yeah all
right so uh we'll see you guys then
and uh thanks for stopping by thanks
everybody that contributed you guys are
awesome
bye